Today, I am going to talk about the homework.
So I hope I have a captive audience, at least those of you who did the homework and and I was the bottom line is that I
was quite pleased with with most of the solutions and I learned something from it.
I think maybe it might be mutual. And we'll also learn something from this.
So there's a hand out that that you have it here.
And number 22 talks about it. So you can be that instead of looking on the screen.
This is hot off the press. They were just, as you are saying, just on my way to class.
I think it's probably not too many typos.
The assignment, as you'll recall, was to take the exercise in Gilman's book, in the appendix, the appendix Gillman's book,
which showed how to how to take a paper from before to after we're after and much simpler notation and the end to use the same ideas again on after,
to get a post after whatever the other the next term terminal and something that goes once, once through you.
Even simpler notation. And so now we have a general unwritten law in our department that when we give an assignment,
we should also try to work it ourselves before we ask the students to do it.
We don't always remember to do this,
but it is definitely a policy that we honor on our exams that we that we set the departmental exams that that we always have the answers prepared,
that we think we can work the problems on the day that we give the assignment.
And when we publish answers later on, we also will improve them based on solutions that people actually did in the exams.
But the but we're supposed to have we have worked the problems before we give them.
And and that has actually not always been the policy of the equipment that was introduced because
of some surprising errors that occurred that were where people had completely unscathed.
They thought that the problem could be done in an hour and it took a couple of weeks and things like that.
And when they actually got to working on it. So anyway, I did the same with his homework assignment.
I tried to solve it before. I, I dare to sign it, too, because I didn't know, you know,
unless I I've gotten to the end of it that it would actually be possible to go through and improve on Gillman's work at all.
And so I present in solution one here. The thing that I wrote out.
In fact, I wrote this solution a the same day as I wrote the handout that you got assigning the homework.
So when you saw the homework problem, Phyllis typed this also the same day.
And so I had both of them sitting there in front of me and I. And this is just a rewrite.
So the final sentence by sentence, pretty much the way the other one was.
And I don't want to read it to you know, you could read it at your leisure.
But I want to point out something about the things that I did change in the theorem,
that if you if you remember the actual theorem had had a more complicated property in it.
It said in the in the it said if alpha beta are unequal, then Alpha is an ace of beta or Beta is an ace of Alpha and the.
And I simplify that because I realized that it didn't matter. You don't have to have that property alpha unequal beta.
You could just say for any alpha beta this is true. Now the reason is, I mean, I changed the theorem.
So this was something that I'm not surprised that that people would would hesitate to do because I didn't say change the theory.
But the theorem, this theorem is simpler to prove.
And and it's it's equivalent to the other thing, because if you have a family which has this property for all Alpha and beta,
then it certainly has the property for all alpha unequal to beta.
That's a weaker. On the other hand, if you have the weaker condition, then all you do is add Alpha to Ace of Alpha for every forever set.
And it works. And then his condition holds in general. And so you can always get from a weaker condition to the strong condition.
And so there was no point in cluttering up the proof and hypothesis with with with this extra complication.
So I simplified it in that way. But that was that was a minor point.
But it's worth it's worth noting for those of you who who who who who got into this problem.
The next thing is that I, I follow the general strategy in here that would apply to many too many other things.
And that is I tried to avoid enumerating things when I didn't have to.
Instead of saying that it's the sequence and sub one. Two and three, I just said, and is accountable set and.
And I so I didn't I didn't say it was a sequence. I just said it was a set.
And then later on, when I needed to know it, I could talk about the case of it or something like,
oh, a carnival set in some enumeration that I don't have to enumerate it until I needed it.
And then I could just need it locally. And for one or two sentences, we were we had it we had subscript that was that was implied.
But easier to understand, in fact, than having having so many subscripts and superscripts all over the place.
So that was the method I used here. And it would end in carrying it through.
It would. It would. Well, it gives a solution, as you see.
And the factor of two, I guess, in in reduction of length.
So although the argument was was the same essentially sentence by sentence, you can sort of map the old sentence into the new ones.
They get shorter in this way. Now,
what I didn't realize in this was that I is it is a trick that most of you actually use in
your homework papers that you held back instead of you didn't hold back in the same way.
Not numbering the sequences, but you held back and not in not in not naming the correspondence with a notation.
So here in other words, I had to set corresponding to Alpha is called ense of Alpha.
And a lot of you in your solutions, you didn't do that.
You just said in the proof let N.V. the set corresponding to Alpha.
And, you know, are you. Or you say, well, we will call this the corresponding set or the.
In fact, it was a better word in the counterpart. Yeah. And and that was nice.
So it would turn out like that was another way of of of holding back on introducing notation when you didn't need it.
So so I had. So I still was was hung up on the idea of, of putting an alpha in this, in this thing and in this sequence that I named,
I decided to call it Alpha one, Alpha two in that way instead of the way the way Goldman had done the other one.
So but I didn't need that. I could have just said C was the corresponding set throughout.
So so anyway, this is my solution. However, I didn't rewrite it again after finding out that the better ideas from from you guys.
Now, the one that I like best is solution B of all the ones that were submitted.
And this is this has two really not three, four really nice aspects to it.
So I want to emphasize them now in words. And then you can read them again after class.
But here he just says, we'll call this sequence. We shall call.
He says, it's OK. I got it. I got by me.
I don't mind a shout, but you could call the sequence of ordered pairs corresponding to offer the counterpart of Alpha and vice versa.
Now, it turns out counterparty is a nice word. I haven't been abused for any other purpose in mathematics.
So when you get the counterpart, you're going to remember it also has the right feeling for this problem.
So when you get to the thing here, you can talk about the counterparts.
OK, now. So the other thing he did was in Islama.
He changed it from an ordered pair of sequences, two sequences of ordered pairs.
Now, this is really the same the same thing. If you have two sequences.
Those are two arrangements of numbers on a line. But there's also it's a sequence of columns, each of which is an ordered pair.
And. And now this was a seat seemingly minor change, but it actually meant that now you could think of the columns, the end and so on.
The TSA values as if they were just a pair and t. And this was.
This is really like a function that maps and into t that.
Very natural. While the Pinsky's proof had this very indirect.
You had to go from into T by snowing that in some K was mapped in the Tesuque.
Well this is a but it's mine. But paying in his solution here discovered that that really it was a map that.
So you think of it as an ordered pair rather than I see two sequences that are someone going in parallel.
So, so, so that was a nice way to cut through the logic of the argument and realize that that was a.
That I think was an excellent discovery. So. So what happens is that when you get this will once you make that change,
then you can go through the theorem and actually come to a point where not only can you check it, but you can understand it.
The theorem. You can you can sort of. You can sort of.
I don't know, though, the best way I could I could say as to what this accomplish was that the theorem,
the proof of the theorem is now factored into two parts which have a simple interface between the parts.
There's one part that you can understand in itself and then you can understand the second part.
And there's a simple connection between the two parts and that.
And he explains that it is in this theorem and he says that he first constructs the sequence of FBN with the property.
For all Alpha and for all beta now for there is an ordered pair ente in the counterpart of Beta with this property that relates NTN and Alpha.
So. So here he gets a note. This is the sort of a Alema subgoal that goes between the theorem and the final and the final proof.
And this is the interface between the two the two halves of the proof.
That's like taking a large computer programing and dividing it into modules that you can that you're going to sign.
Two different programmers.
And they don't have to know much about except they have to get to this, know the subgoal and you can get from there to the end.
And that's Lipinski's proof in my my right up of the thing.
Everything was all was all one one big muddle. I mean, one not model, but, you know, it's on one page, but it's it's a bigger model.
Everything was you were doing both things together, a little bit of one, a little bit of the other.
And so you had to keep more in mind. So so this factoring is certainly a it's certainly an easy way to make the proof comprehensible.
And then he says the construction is essentially a diagonal ization technique.
Now, anybody who's been working with countable and uncountable sets will know that Kanter
introduced idealization technique to prove that sets were uncountable and so on.
And so he's he's also relating this and sort of saying, you know, here we're doing a DAT organization.
He's not. And he gives us a clue as to the structure, the proof. Not not specifically pointing out what he's saying, analyzing,
but just by this comment saying that it's essentially the organizations are very helpful to provide.
The reader gives him confidence that he's going to be all understanding and to get sort of a feeling for the for the structure.
So that's that's a really nice thing. But the main idea was the factoring into this into this property.
And then he re re reinforcing the property at the end, he says.
Moreover, the sequence has the desired property, repeats the property here, and we can now check it at this, at this.
And so we've got the property stated twice now. We could have factored it out into two lemons, Lemma one, Lamma two and so on.
But that wasn't probably necessary because you could do it in a paragraph.
And then the second paragraph shows how having that property is the key to proving the S is countable and so on.
So he gets through the whole the whole idea.
And and you can now also apply some of the simplification Zoome solution A to to make this a little simpler.
Yeah, but but pretty much that's why I like this is the best solution.
It's certainly I agree with the grader who said that it was easier to understand its solution and to understand myself.
Right. OK. Now another.
Now I gave one solution C here, just excerpts of it. So these three dots mean that, you know, there's more more going on here.
And this was just to illustrate some of the better examples of some of the way many of you avoided this double subscripts
just by like here we say we call this the integer sequence of Alpha and you just call it the energy sequence of alpha.
And you don't say it's it's capital, it's a script in sub alpha or something.
You just use English instead of of of symbols. And sometimes English is better than symbols.
Symbols aren't always a winner. So you sometimes you've got to have symbols. Because of what?
Because you've got to have a pig. But holding back and not giving a name to that was what was a win here and that.
And so the way that actually was achieved. Then I give an excerpt so that you can see what the what the central idea of that solution was.
And many of you use that idea in our solution. I want to show you the original of that one, because this what now?
This David Sausen had presented us with two answers like Wilf did when he give us to two extreme examples of how to write, how to write up a proof.
So we have two we have two proofs here. One is for the locutions and one is for the people.
That what is it said a more elaborate a treatment meant to be understandable to someone like myself.
And and here I want to show you the illustrations and you should look up there in color because and
that's I couldn't reproduce them in the handout because they're there and they're in four colors.
And this is now if you if what if we had restricted this to two to two black and white thing, it would be interesting to see what he would have done.
I mean, the directors in Hollywood were were were very resistant in 1932,
introducing color and sound into into movies because they had developed the great art of how to communicate with black and white.
And this was all being lost. They felt as though as as you went.
But but. Color is certainly a very effective thing if you're going to make any brochures or something to do.
Oh, boy, it sure doesn't. Well, when we focus up on it, you'll be able to get the idea here.
But now. So I go.
I give the beginning of it in this in the here in words and end.
There's seven illustrations. And they they build on each other in an interesting way.
So that's what they what. I'll get it here.
But he starts out and he says a function spec of alpha that maps every real alpha to accountably infinite subset of the real's figure.
So here he has alpha and is is some element of the real line in his spec of Alpha, which is a set accountable set on a real line.
Now, this figure is like all any illustration is a can be a bit misleading.
You know, carnival set doesn't have to consist of discrete points. They can have limit points.
They can be all this, you know, things that approach the square two or something like this.
And and so you can't always say if you have a carnival set, you can't say choose the smallest one or something like that.
They might be the numbers one over end or something like that. And you can't choose the smallest one.
So you can't. So a figure like this might lead to say, OK, take a proof.
We'll take the smallest guy in spec of out or the second smallest. So you can't do that.
But it's that's OK. The main thing is you can see that it's not continuous. It's it's carnival.
And. And it in its choosing speck, it sounds like a spectrum or special.
But anyway, it's it's buried in Ace of Alpha for the for the purposes of exposition to the user community that we have in mind here.
Now the caption also is redone. It is for the people who read only the captions and don't and don't read through the paragraphs.
Right now, this is a technique that everyone knows from Scientific American and various other scientific journals where where you.
National Geographic and so on as well. You know, where you where you can browse the articles and look at just the captions.
And so, in fact, in National Geographic, they have quite elaborate captions.
Sometimes that goes on more, sometimes longer than the article itself, because they want to make sure everybody reads the good stuff.
Yeah. OK. So he's the only student who used this idea.
But it's so worth it's about something worth emphasizing cause I had mentioned it before.
So so this is the the the caption providing providing more information didn't just say figure it,
it's it's got a little story going on and there's a and there's this convention in his picture that
he that he that he draws know he has it has an alpha meaning a speck of alpha on another line.
Now he gives figure B which is the corresponding thing.
We're trying to explain the hypothesis that if Alpha is unequal, B, then then one is in in Alpha is inspect the other.
And I amplified the capture a little bit here when I, when I, when I read it and I made another change that David might or might not agree with me.
I'll tell you about now he I used Alpha and Alpha Bar instead of dolphin data.
And the reason is that later on in his proof, he, he had so, so gotten into the, you know,
the use of Alpha in his in his thing that he that finally when he when he when he does to diagnose nation,
he's sitting there with a set alpha bar and bar and t bar corresponding to it.
And those are you know well and and t correspond to Alpha and Bar and Kubi course one alpha bar.
So he's actually applying this hypothesis with Alpha Bar instead of with beta.
Never appears later on the argument.
So I thought it might be wise to introduce Alpha Bar right up front, right from the beginning, filling and playing hypothesis.
You've already got the figure that shows it. On the other hand, Alpha Bar.
Somebody might say, what is this? Is this minus Alpha is is the complement of Alpha.
Is this does this have some semantics or is it just an arbitrary and other real number.
And. And so I. So.
So in order to diffuse that ambiguity, I, I added to two words here.
I said for two reals, Alpha works for any Philipps put it on place to be for any two Real's Alpha Unequal Alpha Bar.
But I think David had only written for any alpha unequal beta and I.
I said any to real self one just to sort of give the feeling there that they weren't related in any other way except being different.
But that's I'm not sure which way to go on that. But what I did make that change here to report it now that the way.
He's done it now, though, he has a color code.
So alpha so alpha dots are are like figure A. in red and the beta dots are like figure B in blue, like figure A in in blue.
And there's a problem when the blue and red want to be on the top of each other. So maybe, you know, I don't know what the right solution here is.
I used Xs and dots to get a black and white, but but he has a convention.
But the main point is now that he's searching for a graphic,
that will that will be a visualization of the mapping from Alpha to spec of Alpha and the
connect and the conduct condition that we have between speck of alpha and speck of data.
Then he goes and gives the figure which says all but a finite number map?
S into the entire set of. So here he has a set. S indicated and S is is being mapped by F one onto all reals and EF two and EF three and two.
Just a body set here. And, and so we're indicate.
And so somehow indicating that, that most of these come out to be all of the all of the whole the whole set of rules.
Now he goes on and gives, of course. No, he gives. Before we go on to prove suppose.
Let's take a look at Alema, which we will stay here without proof.
The lemma says that there is a one to one correspondence as of now. Now he illustrates this lemma by giving another correspondence two to a course.
The two arrows here between something which he illustrates graphically.
And he's got this idea of the ends and the T's where the ends are on the line and the T's are on a plane.
Now, if he had worked together with Paing, he would have given this as a as a single graph where you have N and T coordinates was given.
So that that Peng's idea, having that sequence of ordered pairs means that that you really are just giving points on a graph,
which would even be a better visual for this front,
for this thing, because it's going to turn out that you that those are the those are the things that work out really nicely in the proof.
And I imagine you might even have converged on that if you if you had more time to work on this.
But that's so. So, anyway, we have a visual here that caught that that shows the correspondence and then the improved version
with paying it would be a would just correspond that to a set of some some graph of points.
And the projections and things would be it would be visual. It could be done.
Now, step one. Step two. Step three. And so on.
And he's got and he's got a these things growing.
So he starts out with Alpha and he's cut and he's got various points on the end spec of Alpha.
Alpha went out with two of the three, which each have their own little little graph that go with them, you see.
And this is how they. And this is how the L sequence is being constructed.
Now, you see all these. These. These are these.
These these images. Ah ah ah ah. Remain consistent.
Nesting on each other to build. To build a bigger thing. Now the same idea was used very effectively by quite a similar idea.
I mean same concept somehow was used very effectively by by Peter Knauer and Nicholas Wyrick when they wrote the original.
They're they're the original writeups on ALGOL 60 and on PA. They would start out and they would have they would define the syntax of the language,
but they would also just describe give examples of everything.
So they give an example of an identifier and would give an example of of a constant and they would
give an example of a simple expression and they give example of a boolean expression and so on.
Neith examples built on each other.
And so as you go through the algo report, you would be seeing a story that was sort of being told the subsidiary to the main one.
And you can you could follow the characters as they as they were developing examples of the examples fed together and formed component to this.
Expressions that you were building were from similar parts that you had already understood the simpler parts.
And that he's doing this visually now and it's in these diagrams.
And so then we have, you know, going through the construction, we getting a big step for here, which which which goes from F,
which goes to effervesce some some assumption about the experiment now that the grand climax is steps five,
six, seven, eight, nine and ten and takes us back here where we get our contradiction.
And you can actually follow the follow the thing.
You go through the arguments, you got effervesce. These are the steps that, you know, neither the the images that have missing points.
Then you can go from these to find two to actually select missing points.
And now we would do this actually with Peng's idea, we would simplify this because we wouldn't have it if one is missing a point and we get it.
And a one common theme is that point that's missing.
And so we would get a graph that was just a subset of the complement of this of this image here.
And then that would take us up by through six to a speck of alpha and speck.
The speck of alpha and speck of alpha is an arbitrary element that we're trying to prove is not in in this.
And then we have spec of Alpha Bar, which which then we can use to get the contradiction and we can go back down and we can get down to.
OK. So that's the way. So it was possible to make a visual story out of this proof.
Following the know, following the proof as it was then.
And it was innovative, but using basic ideas that that generalize.
I think when you when you're doing now, this is something that you use most often.
I mean, that I use most often in making a lecture because because in I don't have much enough
of a budget or are to make a lot of illustrations in the articles that I write.
And certainly I don't have color. But when I make an overhead projector, I've got more than four colors I got.
And make a lot of diagrams so I can wave my hands and show people.
And I don't know, Lamport might or might not talk about giving a lecture here,
but I know one of his axioms is never try to give a proof in front of an audience.
And rarely does it work. But if you have some pictures, you can get the idea that, yes,
they could understand it if they go back and sit in a quiet room and and think about it.
And so this is this is a good example of also the kind of techniques that you use for your ordinary
papers that have to go into dry journals that don't you don't have much room for illustrations.
You can still use this technique a lot in court in communicating to people in the when you give a presentation early.
And it would be nice if we could afford this and all the journals and people had the time to do.
By the way, that my experience is that the the amount of work involved in getting a paper published,
if you're carrying it and getting it all finished, is proportional to the cube of the number of illustrations in it in the paper.
And so when I had something like that line breaking into paragraphs and things like that,
I showed you last time, other than those that went that pretty much did me in for a couple of months.
Any other work that I was supposed to get out the door was was impossible.
Any questions on. Come on, you've got to have something.
OK, so I use it when you get your papers back. Yes. OK. After class we decided not to give you before class because you wouldn't be listening at all.
But I think that if you look at the if you read this this handout with the solutions now as you're a little motivated,
after having done it yourself, you might get a complete the amount of learning I wanted to get across there.
OK, well, let's see. Looking ahead, I've got to see a few more things about illustrations of of algorithms.
I didn't have time to finish everything on Wednesday. And I'll base all of this on on volume three of the art of computer programing.
And then I have some other interest introduction of things we can talk about next week.
So after Ryan, through the art of computer programing on the Frontispiece here I have actually if it doesn't,
I think maybe I explain it in the text somewhere because this illustration, I had to prepare it on a Calcutt platter.
This was done in the late 60s and didn't have a way to do it.
But this is a this is a mathematically interesting illustration or illustrates a hash method.
Based on the golden ratio. And if you look at it from the bottom to the top, this is how you can imagine putting things into an array.
And the first one goes in a position point six one eight of the of the total array.
Now, this is the golden mean of the Greeks, the golden ratio that's supposed to be used in in in a lot of ancient architecture.
And if you put the next one, it goes into the fractional part of two times the golden ratio, which is one point six times to.
Is point one, point two.
No. Is that right? Yeah, but it's actually going in here.
It's not the golden ratio square with that goal at two times the gold ratio.
This one goes in here.
But but this this number divines the first the first part into two into two parts which are which are divided in the golden ratio.
And the third one goes into fractional part of three times V, which is which is over here.
And that divides its sub sub intervale into two parts. One is the golden ratio and one is the now is this with this.
This was this was point six. And it's now being divided into point three point.
One point. What was it? Point four, isn't it.
The complement point for and point to roughly two.
And then each each term, as you add in each point, it's the end times the golden ratio or take the fractional part.
And the interesting theorem about this is that as you.
Is that every time you add a new point, it falls in one of the largest remaining intervals.
And it divides that interval and the golden ratio. So they these points stay very far apart from each other.
And and this is useful in hashing because you don't want things to get cluster up.
And so if you happen to have sequential keys and you and you use a golden ratio for hashing,
then this puts them in the spreads, the mountain, the table. So that was used as a as an illustration there.
And I think I did mentioned it when I got into hashing that it was in the Frontispiece.
Now, here's an example on page eight. That is it is it is a clear illustration of my philosophy of trying to give a a
a long illustration of something that that print parents about of the rules.
This one was one to make up. I tried to. The exercise is going to be to to design.
I mean, this is a exercise of thirty three level exercise, which is supposed to be take a while to do,
but is to design a way of handling inside a computer to the way that librarians alphabetize things in the card catalogs.
And. And actually the rules for for alphabetical order in a library card catalog are somewhat hilarious.
And you have to. But if you want to find something in the library, you have to ask the reference librarian or know these rules.
And so I thought I'd say, how could you do this inside a computer if you're going to do a book on sorting?
And I'm saying, how could a computer sort cards into the order the way the librarians do?
And so here these are these are in alphabetical order here.
And the first the first cards, for example, is alphabetized under a, C, C, because you would normally ignore foreign royalty except British.
This was one of the first rules and the thing. So if it's a royal it was the Royal Society of London.
It's under R. But if it's the Royal Society of of here in Rome here, it's it's under a four academy.
OK, now here, here we get 1812 is is alphabetized under a because it's as this is in German language.
You spell it out axing hundreds. Will the next one it says treat apostrophe as a space in in French.
And so the D to Histoire year is is before J tests because it's a space in French.
OK. You have to ignore accents on letters you brown.
Mrs. Does not count in the alphabetization. So J comes before John.
And so then there's other rules like this.
John Brown of Boston, mathematician. You have dates then come in and you have works about somebody following works by and all always going on.
You see the idea here is some of these. Here's the other 1812 overture coming in here as these.
And you ignore articles at the beginning and so on.
And L l in Arabic names gets out and re spell labor with and without the U.
I got John McCarthy in here. John was interested. No. That he was in my book.
But he found out he was only a data and content. But McCarthy comes before a machine.
OK. And s. equal to equal say even in German.
OK. Anyway. No. But my my main idea here was in order to illustrate the problems of doing sorting into alphabetical order,
you will need to know what what the computer program really has to do.
And so I. I made up a detailed. Example like this, which would illustrate the problem of the exercise and then the answer to the exercise.
As you can guess, somebody who has written gimcrack, for example, would be to keep, to keep, to have a way to have the.
The letters here that appear in the card. Kellin then you have a secret key inside that you use for sorting.
And those are all the answer explains that sort of thing.
OK. So. OK. So all these all these little rules were were interested here and says most of these rules are subject to certain exceptions.
And then there are many other rules that illustrate.
That's the main idea of the day I wanted to get at is making a making an example that that is interesting to read, but also detailed.
And I, I tend to to like detail myself.
I'm not sure if this goes or whether everybody gets the books it seems to sell. All right.
So here's another illustration I made about which I worked hard on.
This is I had to arrange the 24 permutations of it to illustrate the idea of this is a section called Inversions of a Permutation.
And every time you interchange two adjacent elements or permutation a number of inversions changes by plus one or minus one and the end,
this is the at the top. You have one, two, three, four has no inversions.
The inversions are pairs that are out of order and at the bottom has no inversions.
And every time you go through one of the lines here, you drop by one inversion.
And so you can visualize all 24 permutations. Why the inversion this way?
Now, in order to get this diagram now, I knew that it formed a truncated octahedron, but I didn't.
But I had to rotate it to a position where these things weren't going to interfere with each other.
And so I made a geometric model inside a mission, inside a computer.
And I was working. I had to work with the telecom plotter here. We had no no graphics.
In those days. And so had it. And so I you know, I rotated and turned it around.
And then and then plotted it many different angles until I found the one that
would that would look that wouldn't that would look readable from from here.
So that that took quite a few experiments in order to get that illustration.
Now, let's see. I'm giving examples of algorithms mostly, though. Let's see.
Or do we have. So here's an example of an algorithm where the construction precedes as follows.
And so so step by step, we go through and we insert and we do things.
So I'm talking about construction here.
Best way I know to explain that construction is showing small example step by step so that you can you can see the the the way it works.
There's actually no. Sometimes this was this chart that showed a construction table of numbers close in here.
Here's a table now. Sometimes numerical tables are considered unenlightening because you have to look at the numbers.
You have to really love numbers in order to appreciate numeric table.
Well, in this case, I think you can get the idea that we have this there's these numbers are getting very close to two.
But they oscillate and they go they go up and down around two and they sort of Oslin period is actually pi,
I think, you know, eventually at three point one four. It changes sine although you can't even tell a difference.
But then here these are these are unusual polynomial.
I wanted to show how fast they converge to two. And I mean, you can't do that graphically because you have to see the numbers so close to two.
They all look like to you plotted them, I think.
So then the reason for this is, given the amount of C, this is always helpful for some class readers to have some connection with with with games.
And so I have I have playing cards on the left and chess on the right suck people into doing the exercises.
Not every not everybody. Not everybody loves these games, but there's a lot of people do.
Now, here's an example of an algorithm where we where I'm doing another step by step thing.
And this is an algorithm that builds to two arrays. And so you so use you see the algorithm and it's proceeding.
And so you have to have. And I worked it out so that to be on the facing page.
The algorithm. And this chart. Oh, so many you've to mention.
On Wednesday when we showed the was showing examples of this breaking a paragraph into lines.
And there was a case where I couldn't get the two. I had two paragraphs that were types that one is typeset by brand X and one is by brand Y.
And naturally, you'd like to have them together so you can see them both and compare the two.
But there was a lot of other text that that had to go between them.
And so you couldn't have them on facing pages, but you can still arrange that one was on the left hand page.
It was on the right hand page and then you can have any number of pages in between those and you can still compare the two.
As long as they're there on opposite pages like that. And Michael Plass taught me that idea of being able to have things.
So, you know, if you had something that you have that that there's no room to get him on face and painted, but you can still get it like this.
And yet they're still facing pages as far as that person has to compare concerns.
Now, you don't get to to give people little cards to carry on an overlap or something like that with which would be the optimal way.
But this is pretty good. Second choice.
So, again, an illustration of an algorithm step by step, by giving by giving a specific instance of the algorithm as to what as to what happens.
A person can read through these and working out with a little piece of paper.
But it takes it and it's the algorithms are inherently not trivial.
So I believe this is the best way known to present them.
Here's a symbolic word. Shows like the possible places where where the next step could put number 15 into the thing.
So, OK. Now, the main part of the text on sorting, I carried through an example of 16 keys that would be sorted by by 20 different ways.
And so I got these keys and they get to get to know them by heart.
But if you keep reading this book, you can quote them.
And and each one has a somewhat different graphic that goes that that is that that indicates how it works.
So when you sort them by straight insertion, there's this idea of where you're going to insert the next key.
And so eighty seven gets inserted before five or three.
And then and then you get to the next line and five, 12 pops up and it has to be inserted after five or three and then sixty one before eighty seven.
And so that's the. And then there's a two way insertion algorithm described here then.
So this shows sort of diminishing increments sort where you compare things that are far apart and you swap them if they're out of order.
And so that's illustrated on the same 16 sheet with a different set of increments you got over here.
Last list insertion. So it's strange.
I don't know what to do about the graphic there. But that was that was it.
Then we had the bubble sort. Here's a bubble, sort of those on the keys.
And here we put the, you know, bubbling up and you got the cocktail shaker version of the oh, the bubbles sort.
And you get batches method,
which which has this kind of another kind of comparison scheme and a geometrical
interpretation by corresponding to folding paper that's illustrated on the same page.
So as far as I know, here's the radix exchange.
No quicksort. This is quicksort. And you know, I use boldface to illustrate the key in which I'm doing the partitioning.
I know the key is that the boundaries of the sub file in which then partitioning, I guess that one of the one of those is also the key.
And we should be doing the partition. Here it is. Quick. Now, here's the boundaries.
This is this is this is fine print, but it shows the idea of quicksort.
Tried to get that in there. Then radix exchange sorting.
It was something where you use the binary values of the key. So I had to give them actually in octal here binary would have taken too much space.
I gave the same keys octal and which you can use to see the pattern of bits in the keys.
It was about binary based method. OK. So anyway. Carrying through the example of the same, the same thing sorted in different ways,
I can help to tie it together but also illustrated the different sorting methods.
Here's the method of sorting those keys where you pretend it's a tennis tournament.
And the winners go to the top and things like that. All right.
Now, the next week I.
I want to talk about two two things. First of all, on Monday, my plan is to discuss getting quotations to use at the beginning or end of chapters.
This is this I think is that is actually one of the most fun parts of all technical writing.
And so I am so looking forward to Monday.
So then on Wednesday and Friday, I'm going to talk about my my fights with copyeditors and and to give you a preview.
That I. Well, I don't know. I got.
According to Dennis Flanagan, I was one of the only authors who ever was able to see page proofs of his article,
because I was so I was so upset with the way that the thing first came out.
And so I so I will show you the some of the things that that the waves.
They ripped off my my writing. When I when I sending the Scientific American and some of the sequels to it and you'll see that I was wrong sometimes.
But most of the time there's this issues in there which are going to be are going to arise.
And also in your own writing. So you'll see this.
So now Scientific American is known for what was known for heavy rewriting of articles that were submitted to it by scientists.
And some people would say, oh, if any of your words survive, this is really this is really incredible.
So I decided I would before I said my article. And I was going to be the first author who whose article would not be touched by Scientific American.
And I would send them something that they would they would accept, you know, sort of word for word as it was.
I was going to epitomize the Scientific American style and so on.
Well, what I got back was completely different from what I wrote, of course.
And then and then these are the and then these red marks.
Here are the ones are things that I felt absolutely had to be changed before we went into printing and over and over here.
And I, I would still much rather reprint the the way I wrote it, but.
But we'll you'll see that story on Wednesday and Friday and some other.
I had a call from ACM copyeditor today and we had a long discussion about whether data is singular or plural.
So she said, yes, that's very shocking.
Yes. And I'll tell you tell you about that also. She says a letter is coming in the mail.
So.